The keyword when I describe the, the performance loss in micro kernel-based
operating system structure is the potential
for performance loss. What L3 micro kernel
does is by proof of construction, they show that they can debunk the
myths about micro kernel-based operating system
structure. Now, L3 micro-kernel, being a micro-kernel,
has a minimal set of abstractions. Has address space, threads,
inter-process communication, and a service for providing unique IDs
for subsystems that live on top of the micro-kernel. The exact details of these
mechanisms provided by L3 micro-kernel is not that critical,
but the important thing is the micro-kernel provides the
minimal set of abstractions as we've been always talking about. Namely address
space, threads, inter-process communication, and UID.
And L3 argues that these are fundamental
abstractions that any subsystem that lives on top of the micro-kernel, or any
subsystem that you want to implement
in the general purpose operating system requires
these facilities. And therefore, L3 argues that
micro-kernels should provide this as the minimal set
of abstractions. How they actually provide it may
differ from one micro-kernel to the other. But
the important takeaway is that, this is the
minimal set of abstractions that a micro-kernel should
provide. Now let's talk about the system services.
Now, as I mentioned in the previous slide,
the system services have to be
distinct protection domains. Protected from one another
and protected from the applications that live on top of the operating system.
And of course, we have this hard line between the applications and the
servers providing the services and the micro-kernel.
This is the structure of a micro-kernel
based operating system. So what is
different about every micro-kernel. The key distinction
is that each of these services of the operating system. They have to be
in their own protection domain, not necessarily
distinct hardware address spaces. The point L3
establishes by proof of construction, is that
there are ways to construct a micro-kernel
based operating system providing these
services. Efficiently, knowing the features of
the hardware platform. In other words, L3's argument is, it's all about
efficient implementation of the micro-kernel and not the principle of a
micro-kernel based operating system structure. So
to fully understand how L3 micro-kernel
goes about systematically debunking the myths about micro-kernel based operating
system structure, we have to understand, the strikes against the micro-kernel.